y viajamos en la historia en directo
américa de france 24 para ello nos
acompaña nuestro cronista de historia al
dolor cordero álvaro bienvenido muy
buena mañana de viernes estos días
salvaros hemos vivido una escala en las
tensiones militares entre china y taiwán
un conflicto que no es nuevo por el cual
es el origen álvaro de toda esta disputa
muy buenos dias raúl bueno pues el
origen de esta disputa se remonta al año
1927 y se empezó a dar muy lejos de
taiwán ese año comenzó la guerra civil
china entre los nacionalistas del
kuomintang que controlaban esta nación
desde el año 1912 y los comunistas pero
en su enfrentamiento interfirió japón
que ya controlaba varios territorios de
china para esa época como taiwán o
manchuria pero que en 1937 entró en
guerra con beijing para arrebatarle
prácticamente todo el país esto unían
nacionalistas y comunistas por un tiempo
pero tras la expulsión de los japoneses
en 1945 el conflicto siguió pero con un
partido comunista mucho más fortalecido
álvaro precisamente este fortalecimiento
de los comunistas el que llevó al poder
a mao zedong
así es raúl para 1949 el ejército del
kuomintang liderado por chiang kai-shek
colapsó y cedió ante el avance comunista
es en esta huida cuando casi un millón y
medio de nacionalistas se refugiaron en
la isla de formosa que es lo que
actualmente conocemos como taiwán mao
declaró la república popular china en
beijing y los restos del comentan
trasladaron su capital a taipei desde
donde tenían la intención de volver al
continente chino en algún momento para
ganar la guerra pero esto raúl nunca
sucedió claro por entonces porque mao no
es invadir también en taiwán después de
cruzar a los nacionalistas del
continente pues la respuesta es por el
apoyo que tenía de eeuu taiwán en un
contexto de guerra fría washington
prestó su ayuda a los nacionalistas e
impidió el acceso a la isla a las tropas
comunistas de mao zedong es así como se
creó el statu quo que vemos en la
actualidad durante los primeros años
prácticamente toda la comunidad
internacional reconocía como la china
legítima a la instalada en taiwán y como
un gobierno y legitimó al comunista
liderado por manu desde beijing pero
esto empezó a cambiar a partir de los
años 60 cuando la china comunista se
enemistó con la unión soviética y a eeuu
le convino reconocer al gobierno de mao
como el válido a partir de aquí taiwán
es relegado de prácticamente todos los
organismos internacionales y a día de
hoy raúl apenas 13 países en todo el
mundo lo reconocen como una nación y me
imagino álvaro que el no tener
reconocimiento influyó
internacionalmente en taiwán en el plano
diplomático desde luego que sí pero ya
que es considerado por la mayoría de
estos estados como un territorio que
forma parte de china pero la cuestión es
que en la práctica ha seguido
independiente va a beijing y con unos
fuertes lazos comerciales y militares
con eeuu que lo considera una pieza
fundamental para contener a china y
aunque beijing trató de incluir a la
isla en el proyecto de un país dos
sistemas que desarrolló en otros
territorios como hong kong o macao
taiwán se ha mostrado siempre muy
reticente a quedar bajo el poder
político chino
y una parte de la ciudadanía ha dejado
de sentirse china raúl claro es decir
después de más de siete décadas muchas
de ellas quieren entonces formar un
estado independiente a china así es raúl
aunque el objetivo inicial del gobierno
de taiwán era volver en algún momento al
continente chino para retomar el poder
en beijing y vencer a los comunistas
después de 70 años se ha asumido que esa
realidad es prácticamente imposible y un
sector importante de su población entre
ellos su presidenta quiere construir
constituir a taiwán como un estado
independiente a china y esta cuestión es
algo que no está dispuesto a tolerar el
gobierno de siguen pin que se ha
mostrado muy contrario a cualquier
intento de sucesión que de cualquiera de
los territorios que considera que son
parte fundamental de la unidad de china
esta es la gran razón por la cual hemos
vivido un aumento de la tensión en estos
últimos días raúl pues álvaro gracias
entonces por esta explicación histórica
los remontamos el origen digamos de esta
disputa de estas pues malas relaciones o
no relaciones digamos entre taiwán y
entre la china continental esto también
después de este aumento de tensiones de
la visita de la presidenta de la cámara
representantes nancy pelosi a la isla al
bar muchísimas gracias pasamos a hablar
de economía